hi Kristoff I love using Cloud functions
on Google Cloud but debugging is a lot
easier on my local laptop
Martin the
how to develop and debug your Cloud
functions on your local machine
[Music]
thanks for joining me today Christoph
what do you do for a living
engineer at Google based in Munich
help customers develop their workloads
specifically for the cloud
so you must have heard from customers
who want to debug their Cloud functions
on their local machine right
yes that's a common questions
if you want let's do it right now and I
will show you how you can do it
but I don't have all of Google's Cloud
here on my local laptop how could I
debug code that is meant to run on top
of Google Cloud
well Google is committed to be the most
open Cloud we open source a lot
so you can actually run small parts of
Google Cloud on your laptop
for example the framework around your
code in Cloud functions is called the
functions framework
and it was fully open sourced
so you can use it on your own machine
and run Cloud functions on top of it
it is not an emulator
it is the exact same code Google is
using for its Cloud function service
in production
all right so how do I get the functions
framework
you can install it with your language
specific package manager
it this is what it looks like in note
just run npm install
Google Cloud functions framework
there's a function framework for each
language we support like go Java python
PHP rubian.net
nice
now that we have installed the framework
let's debug a function on my local
machine
here is an example
when you upload an image to your cloud
storage bucket this particular Cloud
function identifies what's in the image
using the vision API and write that
metadata back to a database
that's a lot happening in a single
function
let's start simple
we will run a function triggered by an
uploaded file and store back the name to
firestore
by executing the following command we
start the function framework locally and
point to the function Handler
we now expose the cloud function on
localhost port 8080
cool now how do you call that function
so it actually runs
to invoke this event-based function you
can use a single curl command towards
the localhost endpoint
there's a particular comment
holding an event Arc event for an image
upload it to a cloud storage bucket
payloads for other event dark events
like in Cloud audit log you can look up
the link docs in the description of this
video
it will guide you how to create payloads
for other events
all right what happens when it runs
let's run it then
the image which is referred to in the
event payload actually exists in my
bucket
so my local function can pick it up
here you can view it in the cloud
storage bucket
and if we check the firestore database
now we see that the uploaded file name
was added by my local function
got it but the firestore database isn't
running on your local machine is it
that's right Cloud firestore runs in the
cloud we are not using an emulator here
it is a remote API call made by a client
library in our function here in the code
it is using my personal account
credentials to do that call
but when your function runs up in the
cloud it will run as a service account
and not as your personal account right
that's right I ran gcloud Oz application
default login before
that means the API call to firestore
will use my account
when my code has been deployed to the
cloud it will run under this particular
service account instead of mine
let's use this service account when we
are testing the function on my local
machine
that way we can reduce the risk of
access problems after we have deployed
it
we can impersonate this particular
service account by running the following
command
gcloud auth application default login
impersonate service account flag and
then add the service account we actually
want to use locally
got it and your code worked before doing
this so impersonation is an optional
step
it is it is an optional step
I could keep my personal credentials
when testing locally but this way I'm
testing the service account Privileges
and roles based by the deployed function
right right we and we'd like our Dev
environment to be as similar as possible
to the production environment right I
agree
um so for the next step let's add the
call to the vision API now currently our
function is only saving the name of the
uploaded image file
we would like to store the object
visible in the image instead
for example if someone uploads this
picture
we would like to write to the database
that there is a cat in this particular
image
let me enter the code calling the vision
API and distracting this information
first add the vision API client
use it for detecting labels
and grab the annotations from the
response
right the vision API is very useful for
this sort of thing it's good at picking
out objects and images as you said but
it returns a pretty complex data
structure if I remember correctly
yes I also never remember the exact
structure let me add a break point in
Visual Studio code and then we can look
at it and find out the exact structure
now I will run my function using the vs
code integrated debugger
I have
that command as a script in my
package.json
now that the breakpoint is there
I will invoke the code again with the
curl command
it will stop at the break point and we
can inspect the current variable
assignment
and here is the response
returned by the vision API
now that I can see the structure I can
rewrite the code to extract only the
object labels in the picture instead of
the full blown up object
let's invoke and test those changes
again
I will run the curl command for that
once more
then let's open firestore and chat
here it is
we can see the image name as the key
and a set of labels extracted by the
vision API
and I noticed that you didn't have to
restart your code to run the new version
how does that work
I used note mod
it restarts whenever it detects a file
has changed nice I really like hot
reloading
me too
many of our customers actually they use
typescript instead of node.js
we have to add a few things to get hot
reloading working for typescript
we need to watch for changes
compile the typescript files and restart
the function framework but this is fully
possible
and all this code is available on GitHub
yes the full type field example is
available on GitHub let's add the link
to the show notes Here
you will see that also you can use
remote storage secrets from Secret
manager and inject them as an
environment variable in your local
development setup in this example stored
on GitHub
I have all written up this and other
best practices in a blog post
excellent I will add the link to your
blog post too thanks for showing us this
Christoph
it's a pleasure and thank you everyone
for watching if you have questions for
Christopher me please add them in the
comments also let me know if there are
other serverless topics you'd like to
see in future episodes I read every
single comment until next time
[Music]